the glare the glass the glirst is real
time to see what this
glirst is all about
at golden god 69 jack griffin from ap
bio is so handsome
probably my man crush monday ngl
does it just have to be monday if you
really really believe when you really
really focus
it can be your man crush tuesday
wednesday thursday friday
not saturday that one is reserved for
the saved by the vale reboot and then of
course he's your lazy sunday man crush
kit
and harkie winslow says is ap bio good
are y'all just attracted to glenn either
way i'm a watch
okay it's good whatever whatever it
takes whatever makes you happy you like
it
i love it okay not jamelle glenn
howerton in gray sweatpants
and ap bio was a gift happy birthday
merry christmas
if that's what you want to unwrap you
got it
this one comes to us from brad bakshi
i'd like to thank the costuming
department for glenn wearing
gray sweatpants and ap bio oh
brad bakshi you knack sheet it's
certainly not the point of the show
that i'm handsome but i guess it doesn't
hurt if there are some people who think
that i am
so patton wrote really got into the
story of the new episode of ap bio but
had my corneas burned out
when glenn howard turned slightly to the
left
and a bit of breeze caught the top
follicles of his hair
and blew it all over thanks men
i like that i burned your corneas out
okay uh gene villapeak wrote
i was glirsty but then i had a glass of
glamone
is that what blurst is how about glen
howerton you could cut glass with that
jawline
like they do in a circle on glass in a
heist movie
you could rob a bank with that job i
don't know i feel like
i feel like my face is thin i guess i
should try cutting some glass with it
later today i'll let you know how that
goes
mary wrote first things first let me
obey my glirst or me a tall glass of
glenn howerton
that's just practical because if you're
thirsty then the only thing that's gonna
satisfy your glirst is a
big old tall glass of me so that's just
good advice is what that
what that tweet is okay lyric glenn why
don't you throw me in the air like you
throw
all them apples and miss the trash can
how about that so she wants me to throw
her in the air and miss the trash can
and that would that would be the thing
that would satisfy her glares right on
okay well i guess now i know what the
cast really thinks of me
stream season 3 of ap bio and peacock
now
[Music]
you